hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress in a match the
finals of the first American chess
congress lupus and versus ball trials
more feet this is game six as the title
suggests legendary game six why are why
is this game legendary and the others
are not we'll just have to check out the
game and then we will be able to decide
for ourselves is it or is it not but
current situation in the match after
three games morphe won one then the
second game ended in a draw morphe very
depressed then more if you lose this
game three then again more fish strikes
in Game four then again a draw in Game
five and now we reached this game and
it's quite the game some of you might
have seen it as book authors are often
enjoy putting it in their books as its
it's useful for a lot of things but
let's let's check it out so Paulson
opens with E for as he usually does we
have E 5 by morphe night of three Knight
to c6 and now they go into the four
Knights Knight c3 Knight to f6 the four
Knights game Bishop to b5 and now Bishop
to c5 so both players just rapidly
developing pieces we have castles by
poles and castles by morphe
and now posting goals for Knight
characters on e5 it's it's a it's a
sneaky line that after Knight characters
you go d4 you win your piece back and
you trade off some of the pieces but
more fee shifts this into into a
variation where black actually
sacrifices upon so he just goes rook to
e8 offers Knight characters and c6 so he
can develop his pieces even more rapidly
and now if this was a modern game a
modern modern master modern master would
probably and give back the piece with
Knight of three we'd have a knight
captures any four characters capture c3
and then follow up with the d4 end the
game continues where white also wants to
get some development in but in those
days it was a route to do to give back
pawns
so Knight characters and c6 by Paulsen D
captures on c6 and Bishop to c4 now and
here Paulsen kinda wants to trick morphe
a bit because if more if he goes for the
for the pawn now then a Paulsen has
Bishop captures on f7 and after
characters tonight captures you will not
be able to capture with the rook because
of Queen to every trick just gobbling up
the rook and now at the Indian at the
end of the line you are simply up of the
exchange in a better position
so after this Bishop to c4 move there
are some there are actually two games I
found in the database from 1996 where
this position was actually reached where
black went and Knight to g4 and black
was able to win both games but more feet
when the b5 he kicks away the bishop and
it is as a move 80 that to this position
has never been reached again so best
should be back to eat you by paulsen and
only now Morphy wins back his pawn
Knight character snide characters in the
rook characters on e4 Bishop to f3 now
going after the c6 pawn but the rook the
e6 of course keeping an eye on the pond
but also ready to shift the rooks
tomaybe f6 g6 or h6 if needed for the
attack we have c3 now preparing d4 if
white can get d4 in then white should
definitely be okay but morphe prevented
with Queen to b3 says nope you are not
developing this way so Paulson has to
figure out a different way how to
develop his pieces he finds b4 and okay
better back to b6 and now a four he
wants the trade trade pawns here maybe
get the Queen to a4 and then maybe kick
away the black Queen via Queen to a6
going after d3 morphe says okay big
characters on a4 we have Queen captures
on a4 and now Bishop to d7 defending the
d7 pawn once again and now Paulsen
doesn't go Quinta a6 right away but
instead first goes rook to a 2
he wants to he wants to keep an eye on
the the the to pawn and also he'll have
the row help out with the defense of the
second rank but maybe Queen 286 was the
way to go right away because here morphe
goes rook 8 e8 and here Paulsen goes
Queen to a6 and we reach this tension
the position from the thumbnail now it's
hard to blame Paulson for this Queen
day6 mode move because if you if you
just check it out it doesn't seem like
there's something wrong with it and even
your engine
you put this position into your engine
will not do anything wild unless unless
you you let the engine go at it for a
while the engine has to crunch some
numbers and then only at the depth 31
does the engine reveal a secret here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find how morphe punished louis Paulson's
insolence that is a queen to a6 while i
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's not easy to find
like I said Queen a sex is only a
blunder at the depth 31 and for those
who just want want to enjoy the show its
Queen captures on f3 this is well more
if you played and it took in 12 minutes
to calculate all the ins and outs of
this line so there you have it more if
you requires 12 minutes to calculate
depth sir 31 and now white is just down
a piece there is not much to do here you
have to accept the Queen otherwise you
can continue playing the game being down
a piece and that's basically
surrendering so of course Paulsen
accepted the Queen sacrifice G capped
for some f3 and now more if it continues
the attack rook g6 check there is only
one move for white King to h1 and now
comes Bishop to h3 preparing Bishop to G
to check and there is not much you can
do about this for example if you block
Luke do you want then black just
captures captures and the rook goes to
e1 with Czech Queen has the block only
move and rook captures an f1 is made so
this is not possible so after Bishop to
h3 rook to d1 was played by Paulsen
but now Bishop to g2 with check we have
King to g1 Bishop captures on f3 with
check King to f1 and now Morphy repeats
Bishop to g2 with check here after I
know exactly the one at which point but
Johannes Tucker thought I found an even
quicker way for black to win here took
it or showed that it just worked the g2
is enough just captures on f2 and
there's pretty much nothing white can do
for example if Queen here captors king
g1 cat person g2 check and now wherever
the King goes Ruby g1 will be made as
here it's it's a double check so both
pieces deliver mate so this was the
quick
way to do it but morphe I think more if
he wanted to have have some fun here and
he went for the most artistic way he
went Bishop to G to check came to G one
Bishop back the h3 check only one move
for the King King to H one and now
Bishop captures on f2 are taking away
the g1 Square from the White King and
now threatening Bishop to G to mate and
there is only one move that prevents
made here and it's Queen to f1 Paulsen
has to now give back the Queen which he
does morphic captures that Bishop
captures we have rook captures and now
rook to e to completely not nullifying
any mobility of Poland's pieces the rook
can't really do anything you cannot push
the pawn because you lose the rook the
bishop doesn't have anywhere to go and
there is not much to do here Paulsen
tried rook to a1 with the idea that he
wants the free his dark square Bishop
but more fee plate looked at h6 even
invites it and there's there's not much
to do here pause and play d4 opening up
a discovery against more fees rook but
once again feel free to pause the video
and get this legendary game to an end
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the only
move that really wins and for those of
you who just want to enjoy show its
Bishop to e3 just blocking the attack
towards the rook and here there is
nothing more to do and it was in this
position unmoved 28 that Louis Paulsen
resigned at the game and this beautiful
beautiful game was was played by by both
of them but but mostly accomplished by
Paul Morphy so really a brilliancy that
Queen captures F to remove
really brutal stuff here he resigns
because if captures then is just made
look character schemes you want and rook
here is made and if you don't go for it
you could the only move that prevents
mate is rook f2 but that's just super
ugly because still more features goes
characters and after captures it seems
like you're just down the exchange but
after captures here with check this is
forced rook h1 check King has to move
wherever doesn't really matter and then
you capture the rook here and even if
wide reach
accuracy will again be up a whole rooks
up not much not much point in playing
this so after Bishop to e3 Paulsen
resigned and before we ended the video
let's just check out that death Beauty
one more time that Queen captures and
have to remove really really really
awesome stuff so Quinta a6 try and put
this to your engine I don't know maybe
unless you have like a really super
engine it will not it will say I Blair
black slightly better but then adept 31
really goes crazy says oh yeah Queen
captures an f3 that that's the stuff
so yeah that's the game that's the game
six of the match Paulsen versus morphe
1857 first American chess Congress I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank matheus Jakob Dario is Ivanka
which Andrew Perry oven wolf and
Alexander afanasiev for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video serum
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world which is
mostly online events so thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and don't forget to show
this game to your friends at the bar in
the library